sofia âgées 51 ans je suis responsable
d'entreprise dans le secteur de la
restauration et de la formation
professionnelle est également
conseillère départementale dans le
canton cette plaine des palmistes saint
benoît
alors le canton 7 se situent dans l'est
de l'île de la réunion alors c'est un
compte c'est un canton part d'un
complexe à appréhender au vu de son
étendue sa géographie mais également de
sa population différente selon les
quartiers ce canton comprend une commune
entière des eaux la plaine des palmistes
en forte mutation et la partie de saint
benoît avec des espaces agricoles dans
les eaux mais également dans les bas il
y a également au niveau de saint benoît
des zones urbaines résidentiel qui
regroupe des commerces des zones
commerciales qui ont atteint leurs
limites d'expansion et nous avons
également sur saint benoît un centre
urbain qui a perdu de sa centralité et
de son dynamisme notamment à cause de
déménagement de certains commerces et
aussi de l'hôpital en périphérie urbaine
alors je suis une fille de l'est vous
comprenez pourquoi j'y suis très attaché
c'est là où j'ai grandi c'est là où j'ai
fait mes études autant sur la plaine des
palmistes sur saint benoît et en tant
que tel et je les dis aussi dans mon
engagement citoyen au travers de
l'engagement politique c'est de
travailler pour ce canton qui me tient
particulièrement à coeur avec une
réalité qui est notre âme mais aussi
notre force et pour lequel pour nous en
tout cas dans cette mandature nous
souhaitons enfin un rattrapage un
réquilibrage de ce territoire qui a
besoin d'un stade à souffle niveau pas
l'est des solidarités c'est notre projet
et l'action sociale est au coeur de ce
projet solidarité entre générations
solidarité entre territoires donc
incontestablement tout ce qui va
permettre de lutter contre la pauvreté
et améliorer le quotidien des
palmiplainois et des médecins égyptiens
seront les dossiers prioritaires que
nous défendrons pour ce canton 7 g la
délégation épanouissement de la jeunesse
innovation et modernisation de l'action
du département en accord avec le
président le melkior je porterai donc
une politique départementale
partenariale renforcée en faveur de la
jeunesse en effet nous souhaitons au
cours de cette mandature porter un
regard neuf sur nos pratiques d'action
sociale et nous croyons que l'innovation
sociale est un domaine capable
d'apporter des réponses adaptées
aux défis de la société actuelle liés
notamment à la pauvreté la jeunesse ou
encore le chômage alors dans ce cadre le
programme départemental d'insertion 2022
2025 que nous allons écrire ainsi que
les partenariats des réseaux d'acteurs
institutionnels ou associatifs qui ont
également comme priorité cette stratégie
sont pour nous des outils sur mesure qui
devrait nous permettre de réaliser et ce
beau chantier de l'épanouissement de la
jeunesse réunionnaise donc concrètement
du pilotage de l'évaluation de la
transversalité entre les services du
partenariat de la coopération en
privilégiant le mode projet et en
renforçant la proximité sur chaque
territoire c'est le sens des dossiers
que je vais porter au sein de cette
délégation
alors le département c'est l'action
sociale c'est la proximité c'est
l'entr'aide c'est également aller vers
les plus démunis c'est donc tout
naturellement que je me suis orienté
vers
vers ces élections parce que ça
correspond aussi à qui je suis et
notamment ceux dont j'ai envie de faire
d'agir pour les autres au travers
d'actions concrètes qui améliore leur
quotidien